they're my words he's falling for me how
are you thinking people are gonna
receive this film with Jamie you know I
think people are gonna really relate to
this and there's a really deeper message
there's like different layers of morals
in this that I think everyone can get
behind and hopefully even like I hope it
sparks a certain amount of reflection
and then the viewers a scene that
everyone's gonna love I'm gonna head it
go ahead and predict this one it's the
first kiss scene it was a little quirky
a little awkward
and it was Shannon's first onscreen kiss
so tell me how that was like how it's a
scene for you there's so much fun to
film in fact I kind of had that we had
this original concept never happened
that liked that scene with like the one
two and then the three we're just gonna
be the cover of the film and I'm pretty
good drawn out in like old 70s format or
something how dope would that I would
have been really know this seems great
super cute I love it
you're gonna load it up problem okay you
gotta write that kiss one two ten eleven
that's what eleven the exceeded
expectations she always does that
now Christine she's someone that you
also work heavily with tell me what it
was like as far as that dynamic with you
guys where she's the person that you're
fawning over but she's not really the
one you're falling in love with you know
it's interesting cuz you can fall in
love with someone and then you can like
fall in love with the way that someone
looks and like at first look it's always
like oh oh yeah that's what I want but
then you peel back the layers and after
the fifth date you're like oh man like I
don't vibe with you anymore and I think
I think there's a bit of that you know
although I will say that Jamie and
Veronica never got the chance to even
date to find out if that was even a
thing I got a quick game for you know
you I like games with you listen now
that you are the Internet's heartthrob I
got to do a game of shag marry kill with
you so your your people that you got a
shag marry here are Rob Lowe Freddie
Prinze jr. and Josh Hartnett
marry Rob kill Freddy and shag Josh okay
well let's see what the Internet's about
that one
I mean I'm excited for you everything
that's going on with you is gonna be
great so congratulations
[Music]